hallo Leute und Willkommen zu kitchen
impossible dem Format dass ich sicher
nicht von Tim Mälzer geklaut habe jetzt
schon impossible die neue Staffel heute
sind wir bei Kimchi Princess ich habe
hier tatsächlich schon öfter mal
gegessen aber heute gibt's was ganz
besonderes ich probiere nämlich die
Chicken Alternativen von tinder aus wir
nehmen einfach mal den Tisch der schon
fast fertig gedeckt ist oder
zufälligerweise
hier seht ihr einen Grill das ist ganz
typisch in koreanischen Restaurants weil
man sich meistens was am Tisch grillt es
gibt ja Queen Barbecue aber auch andere
Pfannengerichte und die ist man dann
immer ja auf dem Tisch ganz heiß frisch
zubereitet und Wunder es gibt schon
koreanisches Bier und
kitchen impossible von euch nicht kennt
das ist ein Format von Tim Mälzer auf
VOX er wird in Restaurants geschickt und
weiß nicht was er bekommt ich weiß es ja
schon ein bisschen ich kenne aber die
Gerichte tatsächlich noch nicht
anprobiert ich die Gerichte und muss sie
morgen dann versuchen selber
nachzukaufen ich will mich eigentlich
freuen dann lassen ich sage dann einfach
ich sag einfach ich möchte alles mit
Hindel guck dir jetzt gar nicht so viel
rein oh curien Classics oh Leute da
kommt schon Bestellung aufzunehmen wir
hätten gerne alles mit Kindle doch
[Gelächter]
Barbecue ich glaube mit dem Kindle Filet
hier haben wir einen chicken Salat und
noch mal die oder halt den Namen
vergessen riecht alles gut
[Gelächter]
wir sind ganz krank
professionell mir ein Notizbuch
mitgenommen
guten Reis kochen ist so schwer
auf die Morchel hier
sind so viele
e
wir sind so viele Zutaten drin es wird
echt aufwendig das nachzumachen
Alternative
lecker was soll ich sagen Angst aber ich
bin der Meinung sie nachmachen zu können
das war so krass ich glaube das wird
aber das einfachste zum Nachmachen sein
weil da brauchen wir wirklich nur die
Chicken weil der Chicken Salat wird ein
bisschen schwieriger wegen dem Reis weil
man den Reis richtig gut kochen muss
aber ansonsten Salat das habe ich jetzt
gecheckt und dann wieder die
chicken-bikes oben drauf mit einer
anderen Soße
Barbecue in vegan mit den Filetstreifen
einfach nur viel Gemüse schneiden sehr
viel
wir sind jetzt fertig mit essen wir
werden uns natürlich alles einpacken
lassen weil so viel haben wir dann doch
nicht geschafft unser Bauch ist voll das
Essen war ganz toll jetzt machen wir es
nach jawohl
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir vom Einkaufen zurück
und ich habe mich für die Kinder
entschieden und das Kindle Schnitzel das
sind unsere chicken alternativ und da
ich jetzt drei Gerichte auf einmal
servieren muss werde ich das natürlich
so ein bisschen verteilt zubereiten wir
fangen deswegen an erstmal unseren Reis
zu waschen absolutely musteries
kann natürlich den Vorteil dass ich
einen Reiskocher besitze ich glaube in
Korea benutzt man Rundkornreis das ist
noch ein bisschen anders als der
landkornreis den wir hier in Deutschland
benutzen aber es ist glaube ich kein
Sushi Reis der Reis muss jetzt erstmal
gewaschen werden
in eine Schüssel und geht einfach mit
eurer Hand durch und dann wird das
Wasser ganz milchig und das sollte
natürlich nicht sein
viele Monate später und dann
lasst ihr euch so
ziehen das sind diese dunkelbraunen
etwas festeren leicht so gummiartige
Pilze
ich bin sehr gespannt habe im
Kühlschrank das Wasser Vorbereitung wir
kümmern uns jetzt um den Teig für unsere
Yam Yang chicken beides also ich habe
jetzt ja Japanese Pankow bei brettkampf
genommen weil die chicken-bikes die YUM
YUM chicken-bikes die waren auch so ein
bisschen über crunchy und dann dachte
ich dann mische ich das noch einer Mehl
Wasser Mischung hinzu und dann machen
wir einfach mal jetzt hier einen Teich
ich mache da jetzt einfach mal 200 g
Mehl ist das blöd ohne Rezept zu kochen
ein halber Esslöffel Speisestärke was
würde man ohne Salz machen ich würde
gerne noch irgendeine Art Gewürz rein
machen ich mag das immer wenn in einer
Panade ein bisschen gewürzt ist
rein ich mache da noch was von Pankow
rein
einmal verrühren und dann kommt da
Wasser rein vielleicht ein bisschen
Backpulver ja damals Wasser
ja ich bin jetzt selbstbewusst das ist
mein Teig und genauso bleibt der wir
machen weiter boah ist das ein
gemüseberg ey jetzt wird Gemüse
geschnitten ne Süßkartoffeln macht mir
ein bisschen Sorgen wenn sie waren den
Barbecue Gericht sehr weich jetzt ist
nur die Frage wie schnell wird so eine
Süßkartoffel durch okay Möhrchen
beim Lauch ist es ganz einfach der wurde
einfach nur in zwei große Teile
geschnitten
ich kriegst sogar Tränen in den Augen
beim Laufen
mit Tränen Augen machen wir weiter mit
unserer Zucchini so und die werden auch
noch mal halbiert der Star des Tages
Paprika ich will einmal diese Paprika so
reinbeißen die ist so knackig
daran kann ich mich sogar noch erinnern
weil die Paprika gestern sehr
überraschend kam und die war in
Scheibchen Spitzkohl das waren einfach
so grobe Stücke cool ist auch sowas wenn
du das einmal schneidest und auseinander
holst dann siehst Du erst wie viel
Gemüse das ist fett für ein bisschen
Spinat
packe werde ich die ein bisschen mit
Wasser schon mal hortauen weil die
gefroren sind in die kommen dann später
hinzu dann bleibt uns jetzt eigentlich
nur noch der Star des Tages und zwar das
Kindle Schnitzel es gibt aber auch noch
ganz viele verschiedene
Produkte und zwar auch noch schicken
Wings oder crispy Filets gibt es auch
noch und Nuggets Nuggets gibt's auch
noch also geht einfach mal bei eurem
Edeka gucken welche Tunnel Produkte sie
so da haben ich habe tatsächlich schon
alle probiert weil bevor ich der
Kooperation zugesagt habe weil ich
natürlich alles schmecken und dann habe
ich alle Sorten bekommen und wir haben
hier wirklich gegessen wie die Könige
und das lag bei denen auch so oben drauf
mit dem Fang Gericht sind wir so mit
fertig jetzt geht's ans Frittieren nee
wir schauen uns mal an wie es unserem
Reis geht genau so wollen wir den
[Musik]
und ab damit in den Reiskocher jetzt
weiß ich aber natürlich auch nicht wie
lange Reis gekocht wird ich sag mal 15
Minuten der Reis ist schon mal für den
chicken salad und unser ganzer Salat
hier und die Möhrchen und Gürkchen ich
muss die jetzt allerdings also in so
Stifte schneiden Gurke macht mir gerade
am meisten Sorgen ich habe sie gestern
kaum erkannt weil sie so dünn und fein
geschnitten war und diese Mitte in der
Gurke war auch nicht dran weil das
einfach nur so ein ganz dünner Faden war
und deine scheitchen Steinchen
jetzt aber dieser rote Salat diesen
roten Salat habe ich noch nie zubereitet
also die nächsten Tage bis hier auf
jeden Fall sehr viel Gemüse geben Salat
schneiden wir lieben es ach Chicorée ist
das was man immer serviert mit so einem
Dip oder irgendwie so
bis jetzt sieht das aus wie Diät Küche
okay wir gucken wie es unserem Reis geht
ich glaube unsere Preis geht ein
bisschen gut
aus der ist nicht so schön gar nicht wir
machen ganz bisschen
Sesamöl rein und ein ganz bisschen
wir brauchen ein ganz bisschen Eisberg
das letzte Gemüse für den Tag
jetzt einmal auf und dann geht es an die
finalen Schritte was wären diese
Gerichte ohne Soßen süß-saure Soße
Bulgari Soße welche Soße wir uns auf
jeden Fall kümmern ist die Soße für das
Pfannengericht das ist auf Basis von
dieser
goschwangaste das ist eine Chili Paste
die wird in Korea eigentlich überall
verwendet immer so ein Esslöffel von
dieser roten Paste und Sesamöl Esslöffel
dann nehme ich eigentlich immer überall
merin rein so ja Soße und was ich
persönlich immer noch gut finde
Chiliflocken diese Mixtur für rühren wir
mal was ich noch vergessen habe ist und
unsere Morcheln das Wasser muss
abgegossen werden und man muss sie noch
mal richtig
gut waschen
ich
finde mein Tag so sieht unser Filet
beide aus bevor wir ihn zubereiten also
man kann ihn jetzt auch so einfach in
die Pfanne schmeißen und dann habt ihr
einen knusprigen chicken Wald versucht
natürlich super panieren nee mit schönen
Teig in den einmal rein
Dinge hat nichts funktioniert
das jetzt hier in meiner Pfanne
hatte jemand Frittieren gesagt ich
glaube da Fett ist bereit würde ich mal
sagen schmeißen wir mal unsere
Team Rock darf
mir das nicht aber ich probiere es schon
ein
die schmecken eins zu eins so eins zu
eins wir drehen hier einmal alles um und
dann geht's weiter bis gleich
die Situation ist hier genau die gleiche
wie gestern wir haben sogar von gestern
mitgenommen und dann trinken wir jetzt
erstmal ein Gläschen
[Musik]
drauf
schicken
cool
Champignons oh die Soße also ich würde
sagen das sieht aus wie gestern oder das
muss jetzt erstmal sitzen wir machen
weiter mit dem chicken Challenge den
bauen wir uns jetzt mal zusammen hier
ist mein Reis wir machen jetzt erstmal
als Base unten auf dem Boden ne so
gemischt das sieht fantastisch aus wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere war an dem
chicken salad eine Soße die wie Bulgogi
geschmeckt hat und da habe ich Bulgari
Soße gefunden
den Schritt spare ich mir und dann
machen wir so ein bisschen was drauf oh
ja genauso seid ihr aus noch ein
bisschen Sesam tada der Chicken
Challenge aus dem Typen gemacht mit
Himmel viel lieber unser nächstes
Gericht sind die Namen Yang chicken
beides und da war ja eine Art süß sauer
Soße drauf und ich habe mir jetzt auch
dass sie so runter gekauft ihr könnt ja
mal schreiben ob das Punkt Abzug gibt
[Musik]
immer gut aus und
getaucht zuerst schicken weiß
oh mein Gott
machen wir hoffentlich genauso stark
weiter mit unserem
funktioniert auch sehr gut
ist lecker aber nicht die Soße von
gestern acht von zehn
ja
Süßkartoffel gar nicht so dünn schneiden
müssen und nicht durch
also
lecker geil
ausprobieren wollt bitte beliefert nicht
nur Restaurants in Berlin und sowieso
könnt ihr zu eurem Edeka gehen und euch
mal was holen von tinder [__] aus
Pflanzen Kaffee in diesem Video schreibt
mir gerne wie ihr das bewertet wie gut
habe ich die recreation geschafft und
wollt ihr das Format vielleicht noch mal
sehen schreibt mir das gerne in die
Kommentare und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wieder